need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation what's up believe nation
8 7 I believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in a harsh environment
having to work three jobs and dealing
drugs to becoming a successful Fitness
creator expert and entrepreneur he's
Brandon Carter and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be a victor soonerlater you want to
stop beating victim be a big door you
want to stop you know wider and start
being a winner
you gonna let you're gonna let it happen
to you or you're gonna happen to life
you need to be happens to life don't let
life happen to you take a photo shoot
man regard to see a certain fantasy it's
harder for you
that's good it was more difficult for
you that's good cuz that makes your
story better
that makes your story but you seem to
pursue happiness
lots of become stockbrokers but he he
was so difficult for him they made up
Hollywood movie about it
starring a number one actor on the earth
if this harder is better pause yes she
said stop complained of it
you ain't got no money good being you
better be more creative work hard you
ain't got money for supplements don't
take supplements see you can do it all
all natural
Dennis spends more impressive hey I
never took a supplement look at me I did
it you ain't got no money go for it
anyway I'm from the black ghetto man I
come from nothing I come from nothing
else to me he seems to me crying about
it cuz I can't pay my bills with excuses
rule number two keep moving forward we
have to keep making progress every day
even if it looks like from day to day
you're making no progress long as you
just keep moving forward keep moving
forward keep moving forward it all adds
up and if you do that every day over the
course of years your life would be a
huge success we all overestimate how
much we can do in a year we'll be
underestimate how much we can do in five
years ten years ten years the dope
father just killed himself I was poor
working three jobs I was 15 20 pounds
skinnier and it looked like I was a
failure in the life
but I worked every day I put my head
down woke up early worked 12 to 14 hours
a day seven days a week and I just kept
doing that until I was a rich and famous
and swollen it's not even special I just
started kept going didn't quit rule
number three do the boring stuff a lot
of people can't sit still and edit a
video or like or do something boring
like most of my day even if you won't
follow me on snapchat it looks like I'm
fun you know girls
models and you know we just fly just got
back from London you know the stuff you
know for conference but the best 20% of
do it's really boring you know me in
front of me looking at data and you know
writing copy building sales funnels like
boring boring you know and I think they
see God I think this happens every time
I get a new employee or intern they
they're like that I know say it this way
me math I was gonna be on planes with
models and I and and I mean it's our
fault like me and you like people if
they look they probably see the the cool
you know and clothes because that's I
mean you don't know me just do above a
post of me of me writing sales copy
that's gonna be boring how do I even you
know like right it's not entertaining
it's not worth posting so I but I would
say to these kids to get comfortable
doing boring that way if you that will
stop them because either they're just
chasing the new shiny thing yeah it's
exciting they get a dopamine rush they
can't rule number four meditate number
four is meditation I started meditating
years ago and I met it take about ten
minutes a day I try to do one in
afternoon as well but I usually just get
one in the morning just ten minutes and
what I do is do a kind of meditation
call for pasta
Taoiseach right and this is where you
focus on your breath your breathing and
you focus on your breath and you know
every time your attention wavers you
start thinking about something other
than your breath then you just bring it
back bring the attention back right and
then and that the key is to try to get
10 minutes of only focus on your breath
without any other thoughts it's the
hardest thing in the world nothing is
hard in this and it's okay if you mess
up you're going to everyone does all
right including me probably especially a
TD I'm all over the place I don't know
who noticed but every time I'm on
wanders and I bring it back
that's a rep don't I used to punish
myself for a lemon on water but no I
need to celebrate the fact that I
brought myself back because that's the
rep I lifted at dumbbells I'm working
out your mind and the reason this is
important why you want to do this is
because we remember we said deviated
attention right switching tasks thinking
about things that are not the most
important task at hand when your focus
and your attention wavers you become
less productive so for pasta meditation
or any communication what it does is it
teaches you to focus on one thing at a
time or it help you release get better
at it and the more you can do that the
more successful you'll become rule
number five pay the price
thanks to working a whisper back when I
was poor I used to manage my boys
restaurant there's one three jobs I had
while I was trying to build my business
and become the social media megastar
that I am today at a restaurant how it
works
patrons would come by they order their
food and they get it they get whatever
they asked for then they add the pay
makes sense but here's the thing
see life is different your goals are
different if you want to get what you
asked for
you have to pay first you have to pay
the price before you get what you want
if you want to build the body you want
and it's gonna take years years you can
make huge improvements in 90 days you
can make drastic improvements in in one
year but to really get to that up and a
lead level which I'm assuming you guys
want that's gonna take years of work
you're going to pay in advance
for years
and then you'll have what you want you
want to build a business it's gonna take
years of effort bro laboratories made
over a million dollars last year first
three years of business and then pay
myself a salary I was working for free I
was still out hustling at three jobs
when I started this in three years
I didn't pay myself I didn't start
paying myself till last year now I'm out
here balling me but I put in the work
before you guys have to put in the work
before and no you want to put in years
of effort to to accomplish anything
Earthwise rule number six be consistent
I've gotta be consistent
you gotta be success consistent to be
successful in anything then people say
the people ask me like I have trouble
using this way from I'm sure I know what
do you eat you're like how you can I use
him or they'll be like I know I need to
sell yesterday I'm like yummy that means
you got to comes in you gotta do
something consistently or long periods
of time every time you see success in
life man in any aspect like any aspect
with fitness business academics it's
preceded by a duration of consistency
systematics you can't do sometimes and
expect amazing results doesn't work like
that you can't eat clean sometimes
inspectors good results man you can't
live wait some time you can't work out
sometimes but not evil do this many do
sometimes and expect the results I got
friends who's like yo I've been a bit my
YouTube page it's like in no traction
it's not like well how can you post
videos help me record videos and you're
like oh you know I just post it you know
every now you're doing whatever you know
whatever he says is [ __ ] cuz nice
consistent he's not every day I post a
video every day it's rare did I miss a
day but if you had to bet each day on me
posted video you should bet on me post a
video every day and it's like then
you're like man you do
you just wasting time is throwing effort
away the only energy wait till the time
way that you'll never get back don't
start going to the gym until you know
you can do a consistent don't start
practicing an instrument until you don't
even know what consistently don't start
any endeavor until you know you can do
you can work on it consistently because
anything else is a waste of time
rule number seven want it badly enough
I'm working out man I'm working out in
filming videos youtube videos late at
night Friday night everybody else now
turn it up pardon you office other
[ __ ]
I'm working okay can we're going got the
lights up my working man going for my
most of you guys are foolish mostly who
are bullish you gotta say [ __ ] like yo I
don't have time man all the time I guess
I need 9 hours of sleep I got time to
work out like that how do you put in
that work gotta want it man you got a
wooden then go through and you go for it
but like seriously go for most y'all you
for the going forward the bush and
you're foolish you post all these
dumbass means inspirational memes on
your Facebook Instagram but you foolish
too soft almost all you soft rule number
eight get up early you follow me on
instagram you see my story I will here
between 4:30 and 6:00 a.m. almost every
day and the reason that's helped me so
much is because when you wake up early
the world is kind of quieter we get to
my office quicker because the commute is
easier it's less people around and then
when I get to the office I try to get
here at
or before 7:00 a.m. I get uninterrupted
workflow nobody's emailing me nobody's
texting me my employees aren't asking me
questions and I get three uninterrupted
hours of quality work before we start
our official workday at 10:00 a.m.
that's what I want everyone again to
tenía if I do that every day I keep my
most important tasks done before the day
and starts and that can be more of a
manager or a coach the rest of the day
because I got my most important tasks
done before the day really even
officially started so I'm like way ahead
of the game rule number nine take
extreme actions I posted a picture of
the other day this kid may made some
serious gains like three months
everybody's like your that's steroids
well that's not three months and that's
III I assumed he I knew these guys
wasn't hatin there was someone Wayne but
they were just ignorant about what it
takes what it takes to be successful I
think he's supposed to be lazy
someone must've told you [ __ ] that
life is easy last very touch don't even
happen in the movies life and even even
ease life is not even easy in the movies
not even in Hollywood is life easy makes
you think gonna be easy in real life so
I start to cry get the question easy
saying oh man I'll be traded for this
many years and I ain't got that many I
made that many games I had the kind of
success that's what you're doing man
what you're doing and then blah blah
live do I get into it
tell me are you keeping a log are you
long and everything you eat every rep a
very set everything you put in your
mouth Paul Simon's water you drink how
much you sleep every night you keep it
up detail log without exception they all
said no oh well then you go man this kid
was keeping a log he was going for he
was golf is yeah that's excessive write
down everything you eat everything you
drink every rep every set for for almost
a year yeah that's excessive that's
extreme but you have to have extreme
actions to get this three results
extreme sauce ain't gonna come from me
yogurt actions media over actions will
guarantee mediocre results you want a
spring success we gotta take extreme
action that's what this kid did so I
mean like y'all I don't have time to I
don't have time to Lourdes I got school
I got work you like the first more let
it go to school I know I said it on
sound that's cuz I hear it all the time
you're just old exam every day hey you
need to be going all out top speed 100%
kick storm the castle kicking the door
to guns up shoot everything that moves
do not diss up what I mean this I mean
life and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
learned through trial and error I knew
that being a personal trainer wouldn't
make me the kind of money on it so I'd
figure out a way to do it I love which
was help people accomplish their fitness
goals and then train people but still
make a ton of money so I had no idea how
to do what I was passionate about but I
really loved and made the kind of money
I wanted to make until I read a book by
Tim Ferriss called the 4-hour workweek
now this book is a little dated now but
at the time it was revolutionary in the
book Tim explained how to leverage the
power of the internet in order to create
a lot of money doing something that you
enjoy so that book changed my
perspective and kinda showed me that to
make the kind of money I wanted to make
I had to stop exchanging time for money
in that way I could do what I was
passionate about making a lot of money
doing it however that book did not give
me the blueprint he didn't tell me
exactly how to do it right so I had to
learn that on my own
there's a lot of trial and error you
know but I started trying to figure it
out alright so I started my fitness
business online I wasn't making any
money at first in fact I'm so bad I had
to get two jobs one with the job working
for my buddies moving coming really
tough work 14-hour days moving stuff up
and down 6-story walk-up Sandman and
sofa beds heavy boxes 14-hour days
almost full-body workouts and that was
five days a week in addition to that
I've also got a job on the weekends as a
manager of one of my other friends
restaurants so I was working in these
two jobs as well as building my fitness
business I was working like 80 hours a
week just to survive and I was spending
every minute I had a free time working
on my fitness business study and trying
to learn more reading a bunch more books
it's like a speedy reading course I'm
Irina speed up to about 600 words per
minute and I started reading everything
I could find on business honestly was
years of struggle made a lot of mistakes
that a lot of things wrong but I started
doing some things right and after a few
years of hard work things started to
change
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Brandon on how to have a game plan
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
in your business and if you're feeling
bold leave your replies in the comments
below here we go question number one
what story do you need to change to go
from victim to victor number two what
boring stuff are you going to be
consistent on and number three what
extreme action will you take this week
Brown turn it off you want to plan out
your day the night before when you go to
sleep and the reason we do this is
because remember you want to hit the
ground run it when you wake up you wake
up early you'd only be planning you
wouldn't be working so as you wake up
and know exactly what you do you were
able to wake up kick in the door to guns
up shoot everything the moves okay
that's what you want to do you want to
be thinking and planning you want to be
able to knock that out here's another
reason that's helpful is because when
you think about your day the next day
and plan it out your subconscious mind
needs to work on that thing while you
sleep all right another time you don't
have to believe that and nothing else
just know that it's better to have a
game plan when you get on the field
instead of trying to make up on the fly
all right we can all agree on that raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion and now one drop of my
self-worth depends on your it's suppose
to mean
if you liked this video I want more tips
from successful fitness entrepreneurs
check out the legendary Greg Plitt the
video who's right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
your perception on how you see the truth
outweighs at ten to one so it's a
motivation and why you're doing it